Grant Williams I do not think I have
seen you since you've been a MAV am I
wrong about that I don't think so that's
pretty true I think so look at this and
you have a new glow feeling good feeling
good feeling great I love it how are you
enjoying Dallas I'm loving Dallas it's
one of my favorite cities in the league
um honestly was able to buy a home here
so really feels like a place I want to
be for a long time and really just
enjoyed the weather enjoyed the people
the organization's been amazing so um
season's gone pretty well but you know
performance- Wise I'll get back where I
was supposed to be yeah no for sure so
we will get to that but I haven't seen
you but I have talked to you a lot
because we're in the same fantasy
football league yeah you had a bit of a
controversial moment in my eyes with a
trade that you wanted to push through I
will give you a floor to explain your
point but please put all the details in
it standing and everything and everyone
else can decide okay so I don't remember
what the actual players that were
involved in the deal but it was a very
even trade however at the time the trade
that was made was with a team that was
eliminated from the playoffs however no
air quotes they were eliminated no
listen air quotes are there because
you're about to see why there's air
quotes eliminated from the playoffs the
deal goes through no one's really
complaining about the the actual deal in
terms of players that were sent they
were just mad that the team that I
traded with was out of the playoffs so I
put the trade on Twitter I say is this a
fair trade 85 to 90% favor on my side
that's not true that is not true I lit
said screenshots to the chat Josh Hart
also tweeted and everyone on Josh's was
like Grant's wrong everyone on mine said
everyone but a lot of people say Grant's
wrong and you're again leaving out a
very key piece of this which is the
person he wanted to trade with texted
him oh I'm out I don't even care he said
send something Fair that's all that
matters did he not what did he say
before that he said yeah he said I'm out
it doesn't matter just send something
fair and I sent something Fair like
normally you could I took advant one you
I took advantage of her in the trade
this that year I took I got I sent her
Derrik Henry for AJ Brown Rand Dre and T
Higgins at the time no but I it kind of
worked out for me it worked out for my
team already wasn't do your team wasn't
doing well but then guess what happens
so T's up
veto I'm sitting here like okay I
thought it was a valid trade hour later
they say actually the playoffs are going
to be six people rather than four but
that's obviously a mistake no one's
fantasy football playoffs are four that
was an obvious mistake playoff I've had
fantasy football playoffs 7 before so
let's just say all of a sudden the same
guy who was eliminated is now in the
race for a playoff spot so that same
trade should have gone through but
instead it got V and it changed my
entire season outlook cuz at the end of
the season rre Stevenson got hurt um Ste
uh who else got hurt oh Josh Jacobs got
hurt yes Jaylen HZ was out I think for
one for a couple playoff Ser or
something like that and somebody think
sabotage sabotage my entire team point
is there needs to be some sort of
handbook reference book that we can all
go to to see who's right or wrong
because I feel so convicted in the fact
that I'm not but you want to know what
good even though you made me mad that
day and I think you maybe beat me in
fantasy or I maybe beat you did you beat
me don't don't get it twisted now you're
you're still my friend and you still did
the show so thank you I got this is my
this is my way of saying I might have
beat you but but we're still cool okay
well seeing you here now in Dallas as a
Maverick you have some games under your
belt evaluate your performances so far I
think for me it's been a little bit both
hit or miss in terms of frustration
because the beginning of season very
well was playing some of the best
basketball I've played I started
focusing on you know trying to get my
weight down and everything else and
performances lacked in injuries too
which suck but um getting back to it so
like now recently I've played well and
feeling good about where we are and the
team has been had
a probably I would give it a c so far
season because we've had a lot of
injuries we've had a bunch of guys out
and we have a lot more potential for
where we can be and we're still what a
top six seed in the west right now so um
we have so much opportunity to be a
great team and we're being led by two of
the best players in the league and Luca
and Kai and a bunch of guys around them
that really compliment him D Jones is
playing all defensive season Luca's
having MVP season and Tim Hardway Sixth
Man of the Year type year so um we have
a bunch of guys who are really really
performing and I'm excited to be able to
add to that mix yeah you said that you
have been hit or miss what's hit what's
missed the shot I feel like that's the
most frustrating thing because
defensively I've been decently solid you
know especially in isolation I've
guarded well um I remember when I had
the knee and the wrist injury that you
know you know the shot has not performed
well since and I'm getting back to it
now I think I you know there was some
games I think I only made one one three
so last night I was one for three or one
for four but that's bound to happen they
went in and out so I feel more confident
in the shot that's all that matters
which feels good because before when you
you know your can't even bend your
shooting wrist that sucks yeah for sure
well I was going to say I'm I'm a little
struck by how like honest you are able
to be about your game to say that you
hit or miss to say that you maybe
haven't been playing exactly how you
want have you always been able to be
that way really be able to self-reflect
and look at the role that you are or
aren't playing absolutely because for me
I've always told people it's good to be
critical of yourself but also understand
that you know if you're doing all the
things that are possible to be the best
possible you then that's all you can
really focus on you know people are
going to talk about your performances
that's their jobs you know you have
people that work at ESPN TNT and these
things are supposed to be critical of
your performance you can't believe all
the words that they're saying because
you know how valuable you are you know
what you can provide so yes there's
times you're not going to be doing that
but there's also going to be times where
you're doing it to a level that no one
else is doing it comparably so um trying
to stay even Keel and understand that
being CR critical of yourself is
important because it shows that you have
weaknesses and you can turn those
weaknesses into strengths and I try my
best to keep a positive outlook so are
you able to recognize when a criticism
Rings true about you and if so what
criticism right now do you feel like is
true yeah um I remember just even the
start of season I came off my my hand
surgery and I wasn't in the position
that I should have been to start the
year and coaches and staff challenged me
to get my weight down and since then
like if you even look at the pictures of
me when I first started season versus
now like significantly different I think
I'm down 17 pounds even the past two
months so um super excited about that
and my conditioning levels are higher
you know I might not necessarily have
had the you know shooting metrics to
show but I know I've been doing
everything else otherwise to make myself
be the best potential shape going into
end of the year but also um going to the
playoffs you know that's what really
matters for us and being a guy that play
those 30 minutes that the coaches
coaching staff may need and I'm
fortunate because we've had a lot of
great you know teammates that have
really picked me up along the way you
know we've had the Marcus Marie morrises
the um Derek Jones ad Dante X playing
his tail off right now so it's actually
the performance wise teammates have
really lifted each other up and that's
what this team's all about it's next man
up mentality that's beautiful how proud
are you of yourself to like say that out
loud that you know you had this goal
that you wanted to the weight and you
did I'm sure that feels really good
absolutely and something that I've
always said year-over year there's going
to be something new that you're going to
try and add to your game or try and make
sure you're on top of you know my
biggest struggle in my career have
always been either waight or making sure
that your um focus is fully committed to
the goal at hand you know because you
want to play all the time you want to
play 35 minutes but are you doing all
the things it takes to be 35 minutes
involved you know and even just with the
veterans and the guys I've had across my
career hearing their stories whether
Blake Griffin Kimbell Walker Kyrie um
she Tristan Thompson you know a bunch of
guys who have played at high levels and
then the guys who are in the same age
class of me whether it's Luca JT and the
things that they do to take care of
their bodies so just understanding that
and how important it is at this
professional Level Playing 82 games a
year but also you know understanding
that you're not where you are you're
peaked out you know that's something
that confidence-wise a lot of players
have to deal with in this league because
when you think about you drafted to a
team you're assigned a role and I was in
Boston for four years so I whole time
I'm just saying I'm make my role the
elad possible that I could be for this
team yeah and during that third second
third year was when I realized okay I
have to do more because what if I'm not
on this team you know what happens if I
go get traded what happens if I'm on a
new experience and where where can I
expand where can I be better and that's
really what clicked and since then it's
really been something I've tried to be
mindful of like now I'm in a new market
I'm on a new team yes I can can provide
this I provide the defensive
capabilities I provide the outo outside
shooting but also you know there may be
a time where close out situations making
reads there's going to be different
things on this team especially in Dallas
you're going to be asked to do more and
being prepared enough to do that so it
was like at one point in your career you
realized that there was a balance
between making sure you're doing all the
right things to be a good you know
Celtic at the time you're referring to
but also a good NBA player yes because
it has to be able to translate
regardless of the situation absolutely
you have to be willing to challenge
yourself and realize that you're you're
capable of more you know a lot of guys
get comfortable with this position that
they're in if you look across the league
you see guys that always you know peek
out or plateau and the ones who don't
are the ones who challenge themselves
every single summer to come back better
I look at guys even in tyres Maxi or
tyes halberton and even Tobias Harris a
Boris di I'll try and look at people's
careers and where they started Draymond
was coming off the bench and then beat
out David Lee and continued to grow his
team and his leadership role and and
what I realized is you have to do all
that it takes to really fully Encompass
the person you want to be versus if you
do partial things if you like oh I'll
work out but then you don't eat right
versus or I'll eat right but then you
don't put the commitment onto the court
or into the treatment of your body all
those things matter can you give me an
example of a time where you maybe didn't
think you were capable of more but then
how did you overcome that hump yeah um I
remember especially you know I think it
was my rookie season where I think I was
shooting terribly like I was like people
are keep telling me I'm a confident
shooter I should be able to shoot with
confidence even in the the game seven
against the Bucks I remember looking
back and I shot my first four threes I
made the first one and after that I
missed three and at that point I was
like okay like maybe I'm taking away
from the team this is an important game
let me start passing and I remember
Jason and eay just punched me in my
chest and like shoot the ball yeah you
you've worked your tail off to get to
this point we know how confident you are
as a shooter if you shoot 183 tonight 23
tonight then so be it and I ended up
doing that and that's just a test of the
people that believe in you around you
and realizing you have to have that same
confidence and belief in yourself and
motivation for yourself because um
that's that's vital you know having that
confidence to be able to come into a
role and have that Swagger in a way yeah
and knowing who you are regardless AB so
no I I love that going off that I was
listening to your appearance on Kenny
beachum show and you said that you think
that teams have adjusted to you as a
star
but you don't think they have adjusted
to the type of shots that you're now
willing to take can you expand on that
yeah so I remember when I was in Boston
um a lot of my shots came in certain
areas whether it was Corner threes and
maybe the occasional spot up from the
wing but even now the ability to then
keep those same shots in the bag but
whether it's putting the ball in the
ground to shoot a mid-range shot whether
it's driving I wasn't doing much
penetration to kick out for for others
or even playing in Twan games where
there get where guy hit you on the elbow
and you're able to fake it keep it and
be a little more involved be more of a
basketball player rather than just kind
of I always say a robot you know a
person that's going to do his job and
then go back on defense and then do his
job again right but going off field
going off field and using your IQ and
using your ability you letting that show
and that's something that I feel like as
a player in Dallas I've been able to
really do and when I'm at my best has
been especially more recently um is just
the type of energy that I play with and
the joy you know cuz you lose that
sometimes you know when you feel like um
you aren't necessarily where you're
supposed to be you can also have those
doubts but then you realize you have to
come back into your own and say listen
doubt is good because it means that
you're human and you have to step out of
it and challenge yourself that those
doubts can be be ringing and be there
but I'm not going to believe in them
yeah doubt is good I really like that
I'm G to adopt that mentality because I
think it's important like you have to be
so steadfast in your beliefs and again
who you are because if you're not it's
so easily changeable based on
circumstances and based on emotion
absolutely but when you know that you
can like hold yourself down I think that
you're able to succeed despite and I
think that's something that you need um
in the league for sure I mean especially
now in Dallas there is so much talent on
this team a really exciting team I'm
curious though because you know
situations always are seem different
once we're in them so what did you think
about Luca and Kyrie as Duo before you
were their teammates and how is that
different now that you're their teammate
yeah so it's it's interesting playing
against them you're like wow this guy is
is very hard to guard you you realize
like okay Kai I've played against Kai a
lot because he was in Brooklyn and we
played them four times a year my first
two years and even that following year
before he got traded to Dallas like just
being around him and seeing the work and
his ability he's like a magician on the
floor so I I always assumed kind of what
it was like to play with Kai but I
didn't know how willing he was as a
passer cuz when we played against him it
was always a little more aggressive
scoring he never I never really noticed
that how he got off the ball as quickly
as he does m but he's very much so a guy
that's like okay like I can do this but
I'mma let you play and you can create
for me sometimes and that kind of kind
of took me back when I got here because
now I'm actually having to understand
kind of how he plays how well he is as a
cutter how he not only puts himself in
great position to catch the ball but
also can do a good job of getting you
open just from being a little kind of
bait in the way yeah and with Luca I
remember when I guarded him in the past
thinking wow this guy like might be one
of the hardest guys I'm taking shots and
like his teammates must be mad or like
or this stuff and then I get here I'm
like oh I wouldn't be mad at
this like oh I get it I get it now like
I get why I get why we why this is a
thing because you look and you're like
this guy might be the best scorer in the
league and at times you like I don't he
practices these shots and you're like
there's no way he's going to use that in
the game and then he'll just that hook
shot that he shot for the I think wasn't
a gamewinner by any means but it was a a
thing that put the team away was at the
right hash of the cor I forget what game
it was earlier in the season and I was
like I've seen him shoot that shot and
I've seen him shoot the sky hook that he
made to clutch I was like this guy is is
special yeah and he's also a guy that
like he is a little bit different from
Kyrie he does a great job of making sure
you don't have to do anything Where You
Are like all you have to do is focus on
making the shot and it's a blessing to
play with a guy like that because he is
so he draws so much attention and he's
not selfish in that regard of saying I
won't make the right play if he doesn't
that one possession he acknowledges it
and you'll be able to say okay like I I
saw you like I I got you next time and
that's so refreshing to hear because you
know depending on who you play with they
may not have that they may say like my
shot's a good shot I remember Melo did
that interview where he like yeah I saw
you but I work on this
like Luka on the other hand he's like I
saw you like I got you next time that's
on me absolutely and that shows true
discipline and Leadership and I think
that you know it's something that we all
have to really really be inspired by as
players because we have to do the same
for him like in times where you know he
may have worked to get a shot or worked
to get open and we didn't do our job to
help him out you know same way and say I
got you next time and I think that's the
relationship that we're growing and
building and no matter how many times it
tells you to shut up I'm going to keep
talking yeah you're got to keep talking
well okay so two things one I love
everything said about Luca especially
when you're talking about just like that
hook shot because that was like a recent
ad to Luca's bag he came into the season
with a new trick right and it feels like
every offseason what he does is add
something how can I get better this year
and I think that it's really effective
and Mark cubin has actually spoken to me
about this before too he said that's
what the greats do they come back with
something new and every single season it
feels like Luca does that but then
secondly to the point that you just made
I think that an underrated aspect of
coming to a new team is that you have to
learn the personalities and you have to
see how they communicate with one
another how they discuss mistakes and
then you're also having to maybe adapt
how you communicate because you're used
to communicating how you communicated in
Boston right so how did you have to
change how you communicated on this team
and how did they maybe communicate
differently than what you're used to
yeah so I started off let's just say I
started off incorrectly I started off a
little bit rash I came in a little bit
kind of you know expecting to come into
this role and be a vocal presence and
realized that like I have to do my job I
have to do my job first before even
speaking up and um understanding like
how to communicate because in Boston you
know we were with each other for four
years so we could say whatever we felt
in a way or at least I killed and I knew
that guys would know that I'm there for
them no matter what happens so I was
able to curse JT out or curse JB out and
and they look at me and be may be upset
in a moment but they know it's coming
from the right place versus here I Tred
to do that from the start and realize
that okay let me like at least get to
know these guys before I start you know
being a vocal like trying to be this Hur
ra guy and I've got a good job it took
three or four weeks kind of not off but
in a way of not saying much and just
observing and just understanding okay
like I know how to communicate with
Kyrie now I know how to communicate kind
of with Luca I'm still learning a little
bit but I talk sometimes too much and he
tells me to shut up and I'm like okay I
got you and the thing about I think that
respect I've gain from Luca is that like
he's able to say that to me and it
doesn't affect me and I still will come
down and shoot the next shot that he
passes me or like does I don't shy away
from it and I think that's the
relationship that we're building and
growing together and then even AC down
the line like I learned how to talk to
Maxi or Josh and people who may need
more uplifting and stuff like that
versus others who may need more like you
need to lock in and let's do this like
me and D Jones can come to the bench and
talk about what's whatever's happening
and we can goofy talk about it or we can
curse each other out about it and it
makes it really really you know fun you
know being in a locker room that you
know you have those relationships and
are able to challenge one another while
also understanding that you know we have
one goal and that's winning and and we
need to help each other however it takes
and that's whether that's lifting each
other up whether that's killing each
other just make each other lock in yeah
and also learning is fun right like it's
it's fun to learn about other people and
how they work but when you first
answered the question you said well I
first came in a little rash and you were
smiling
what moment are you thinking about when
you say that oh there's multiple let's
just say there's times where I think I I
try to yell at Luka in practice I try to
yell at Tim during the game and I was
just like okay this is this was not
helpful this was not this didn't help us
by any means this probably went the
other way and it took the energy out of
our team yeah so learning how to you
know pick and choose your moments that's
kind of my growth in a way you know and
also teaches you what you need to learn
about yourself you know there's a
difference between you know when you had
Al and you had guys who were a little
more calming Natures versus now where
you're like you're the guy that like has
to be the let's lock in but also has to
be the guy that says when you notice
things aren't going wrong being guys we
got this let's you know let's pick each
other up and let's move on like that
mistake happened let's move on yeah and
being able to do both and that's
something that I've I had always
struggled with because I was always the
guy that always wanted to win and didn't
care what excuse you had or everything
else now I'm understanding that there's
real real things that happen during the
game and we shouldn't expect excuses all
the time but there's going to be times
where you know sometimes just like okay
don't even have to talk about it you
know mistake was made we know he knows
he got it wrong I know he got it wrong
and instead we just move on and we play
to the next play yeah but also too and
I'm sure it's much funnier now that you
are improving it's a very V it's a very
funny um story to think about in my head
of you saying something to luuka and him
just going shut
up happens way more than you think don't
worry just look at last game happened
during the game and uh he says tell him
to up at the free thr live and then we
just like afterwards we da each other up
a smile afterwards but it's just one of
those where you know with luuka he
really wants to win and there's times
where you know I do talk too much where
it's like we just need to focus on what
we have at hand and not talk about all
this extra stuff and uh it really helps
because I think that that shows that
level of chemistry for sure for sure and
it's just like it's the camaraderie it's
like you have to go through these
moments to figure out like you maybe
don't think about it right now but you
went through these moments when you were
a rookie because you had to like that's
just a part of the the learning curve so
I locker room story of the whole team
telling me to shut the up in the
bubble was was definitely a definitely
uh it happens often if you don't realize
I get told to sh yeah but I always tell
people that's the best way to get me to
understand because otherwise I'm just
going to talk so if you tell me Shut up
in the moment I'll be like all right
cool it's not them saying shut up in
like a derogatory way it's like more so
like all right like we need I need you
to be quiet for a second yeah like can
you literally shut up
yeah that's so funny um um I realized
you wore Luca shoes like all of last
year yeah no there was no there was no
reasoning behind no no that's what I was
gonna ask I I didn't think it was I was
going to say did he notice that did he
ever say something to you about it you
know honestly I we haven't talked about
that I always said like it's maybe it's
because we like I said his shoes fit me
a little bit better than JT's did you
know and being signed to Jordan you know
you always try to find what shoe works
best for you yeah and I'm excited you
know who knows you know I might try the
jt2 out I might like that shoe or I
might try out the Zion 3 and you know
just a matter of what you prefer and
like I think bi and those guys were 38s
you know and it just depends on Luca one
was my favorite shoes I think I've
played in so now okay are you a guy that
will not wear Luca shoes when you're
facing Luca actually I did last year
prior to that I hadn't okay but um the
shoe was just that good I was I can't I
played too well in it I can't I can't
not guard and who cares if he says you
got my shoes on like I was like I don't
care but normally I remember my rookie
year and second year I was wearing KDs
or Paul George's and every time we
played them I wouldn't uh I think K
brought it up one time he was like oh
you want to wear my shoe now and I was
like oh so he noticed but yeah it just
depends that's really funny because yeah
someone told me when I asked him once
about why they will switch the shoes if
they're going against them it's like
well cuz if they bust my ass and they
say hey you got my shoes on now I look
stupid now now I want to fight that's
really how it feels exactly but instead
it's like all right like I'm wearing
your shoes if I played well against you
in your shoes I might as well name them
mine now oh yeah have you ever used that
line let's just say I'm not that good of
a trash talker I can think of it now not
in the game I love that um you I read
love watching Shark Tank so I wonder if
when you first initially met mark cubin
it was more of like a fan moment because
you see him on the show yeah that was my
rookie so I met first met Mark when I
was like a rookie and that's when I was
a real like true fan CU like I've been
watching that show for years and uh
nowadays it's more of like a friendship
which is super cool to me because you
know like the guy in his position being
able to have these relationship with his
players and also um being available
that's that's huge you don't know
normally see that and when I was a
rookie though let's just say I had some
questions I was like what can I can I be
involved is there any way I can be you
know a part of this and this he's on it
for I think hopefully another two years
I think he said he was leaving Shark
Tank or whatever else but um it's
definitely something I'll miss because I
remember watching him Damon and all
those guys you know Mr Wonderful for a
long time I love that that's really
sweet uh now you know of course a lot of
people talk about the intensity of
playing in Boston what do you think are
the differences and similarities between
a market like that and a market like
Dallas yeah um differences between
Boston and Dallas I would say in Boston
you know there's this expectation you
know no matter what there's no settle
for less there's always going to be a
win that has if they expect a
championship year-over-year there is not
they call themselves the cities of
Champions you know and um they're
harshly critical of the players in any
any moment whether it's the first game
or the 82nd game or or a playoff game or
a game that doesn't matter in a regular
season where people sit out you know
it's it's that environment that always
has you kind of on edge like you always
feel like you're looking over your
shoulder and somebody's going to throw
egg at you but you're outside type feel
yeah versus here is they still expect
the same success but they're we're more
welcoming it's kind of like the southern
approach it's like we want to build you
up like they may every now and then you
might have get bash and you might get
talked about but often times you're like
how can we help you you know how can we
help you perform at your best and it
feels like a a family like they want to
welcome you in then families can be
critical of you but they also understand
like there maybe this going on there
maybe that and they're way more you know
warming than I feel like Boston was
Boston's a little more cold and maybe
that's the the environments too you're
in the south in Texas where you get a
little more sunshine and versus in the
north you know it's all clouds and and
snow up there I bet you I think there's
a snowstorm right now and I'm just
thankful I'm out of there yeah like
we're not in the Northeast at the moment
so thank you that I'm not in New
York now I obviously you are on a new
team so I'm not going to talk about
Boston this whole time at all but I do
want to touch on it some because it is
such a part of your NBA Journey you have
not played Boston yet as a Maverick but
you do play them this month what emotion
is tied to the thought of facing the
Celtics yeah and in all honesty it's
going to
be it's going to be cool because I'll
get to see all the friends that I kind
of miss in a way like I missed to JT JB
Derek you know Al Payton Sam all my guys
you know those are my guys there in
Boston and um we had a great four years
or two years however long I play with
each one of them we built a bond and
it's something you definitely have like
a miss a little bit because we also had
success we've seen the failures we've
seen the successes of when we get to the
finals and we lost versus we conf
confence finals and winning it you know
it's a bunch of emotions so and even the
staff you know missing the the training
staff my my guy Pat and Paul and guys
like that and um just being able to have
a moment to be able to you know talk to
him like when we played Houston this
year being able to see eay and being
able to see Ben and all the all my guys
on the staff there was so like
refreshing madebe you just not only want
to compete against them more but also
happy um just to be able to spend time
with them and that's kind what I do miss
probably is just the conversations that
we had you know sometimes on the plane
or talking about our families talking
about our lives and um it'll be it'll be
a special moment we play against them
I'm trying to kill them for sure because
uh just because it's that Competitive
Edge you want to play against your
former team you want to play well but
also you want to you know be able to
talk trash JT at our golf event this
summer so yes exactly but wait so what I
what I asked you said you know I think
it'll be cool because I miss those guys
who want to talk to them but cool is an
emotion yeah the emotion like it's going
to be different being in Boston versus
Dallas I think we play them at home this
year or this this month you play them in
Boston in March yes so at home I feel
like it'll just be more not really much
motion just going to be kind of playing
and getting to know how how The Season's
been what they what they enjoy what they
don't enjoy versus embossing it'll
definitely kind of kind of be a gut
wrencher a little bit away because not
in a bad way but in a sense of like I
don't know how they're going to react or
how the fans will react I know it's
going to be weird like walking seeing
all the staff there because in the arena
staff I Tred my best and learn
everybody's names and like even just the
people that work there every single day
I wanted to make sure that they knew
that they were just as valuable as the
players and so that warm embrace to be
able to say like hey it's good to see
you guys again I know it's been 6 months
since the last you but you know just
know we I still appreciate you guys for
all you did for me over the past four
years and like just that little things
and I don't know I don't know if I'm not
a crier so like but it definitely will
have me like kind of stone fa in a way
of like the same Smiles that I have I'll
have but uh like during the moment when
they call this start lineups or when
this game officially starts it's
definitely going to be a little bit more
like serious yeah so you said that you
know you don't know how the fans react
how do you want Boston fans to feel
about you yeah I feel like there's a
good sense like I have a lot of positive
you know comments that like come back to
Boston and stuff like that and that
feels cool you know cuz you feel like
you left somewhere that really you know
misses you but when you get there you
know you same way you want to be
embraced but if you're not it makes you
even more excited to be able to play
against them and I think I will be you
know because I think that you know I
always think there's some cool moments
we have in Boston whether it's you know
the the game seven Grand is what they
call it just like game seven Kelly every
time Kelly goes back or the times where
you know I got in Jimmy butt in the face
and we lost you know that's there's
there's ups and the downs but I think
the the the memories are going to last
longer and um I'm super excited to be
back there just to be able to you know
get it over not get it over with but
yeah but just know the feeling so that
you can then move past the feeling so
what is it going to be like you think
you know their games so well now you're
going to be on the other side how will
that help you and how will it hurt you
that you so intricately know you know
what JB does what Jason does like how to
guard them like what what goes through
your mind when you think about that oh
yeah I definitely like know a lot of the
things they enjoy but I think they can
use that to their advantage as well
because they also know things that I
don't enjoy on a defensive end you know
so um in isolation I feel confident in
all those matchups just because I feel
like you know they know in isolation
that's where I'm at my best so I think
they'll do a little more strategy of
making me kind of run around screens and
do a bunch of stuff that you know Joe's
gonna try and take advantage of and it's
fun
because JT you know if you look at his
game he's added a lot his footwork is
crazy when I watch him now I always
think like dang like he's really
improved on just like understanding
angles and understanding how to use his
length and size to his Advantage JB's
being a little more passive this season
but you know you you still know what
he's capable of you know he's being able
to you know allow guys to play around
them and D hooping better than anyway
he's allar in my opinion is like an
All-Star guard this year Y and then they
have Chris stops who's even more
talented guy who's I don't know what
option he is whether it's second third
first who knows and same with Drew like
who's a capable Defender but um I look
at that team and I'm like I understand
what Sam wants to do Off the Bench and
how he wants to get a shot off I
understand what Payton likes Payton's
probably I always say pton was my
hardest guard because you know I don't
like guarding small guys but um JT and
JB I won't say what they like to do but
I know that uh there's definitely some
ways to to take advantage of their games
okay nice in Boston who was which Celtic
was the hardest
goodbye hardest
goodbye in all honesty uh the hardest
goodbye might have been Al just because
like I look back to Allen Blake and like
the the impact they had on me my last
two years there because in that third
year I was like my my road dog in a way
like he was the guy and Rob both they
were both two guys that we all knew we
had each other's back as the front line
and we knew how to play off one another
whether it's Al spacing and I would roll
if Rob was in the game we able to play
and he he'd tell me to run when I run
down he'd be like take Joel and I be
like I got you and take and we talk yeah
and so though that would probably be the
hardest goodbye because you know plus Al
is you know what 37 I think he is now so
it's not like we talk every now and
again but like or text or call but like
JT I can FaceTime you know what is he
doing besid it's like Al got his whole
life he got a lot of kids five kids I
got the wife like I'm not about to
bother him all the time but so that was
probably the hardest goodby because he
was just a common voice and both of
those two guys him and Blake both taught
me how to be a professional because you
know it's easy when you know things are
going well you know when you're
performing and you're involved and
you're in the lineup and stuff like that
but in the times where you know things
may not necessarily be the right thing
like things they may be doing things
that you know you may be performing but
they may be not treating you the way
that they should like how to be
professional even with and despite that
and that's something that I learned all
in my last season in Boston that fourth
year was because you know Blake and Al
without them I probably wouldn't have
you know I would have raised the storm
so they kept the Calon head for me and I
was super excited by that amazing so you
were you were blessed to have some good
bets I was yeah I love that that's
really beautiful um you recently called
emay udoka the best coach you've ever
had what separates him the best part
about eay is not only he's good at ex
andos but the relationship that he has
with players you know he's able to
challenge you he's very aggressive like
that's the type of coach that I love is
because I was around Rick Barnes my four
years in college and prior to that I had
a coach that was the same way oh and I
know Rick Barnes was working you oh yeah
that saved Rick Barnes that's not
cussing Rick Barnes that's Rick Barnes
that knew to do war games and mental
games with you so um but eay was a guy
that would like he would come to you
face to face and challenge you like
there's there was games where he'd be
like you soft guard somebody and if you
watch his clip with Braun like how he
talked in that clip that's how he talks
all the time so like for me I I love
that from a coach's a guy that's willing
to challenge me even if I think I'm
playing my best there was games where I
think I had some of my best games he
still wanted more and that's where I say
like eay just makes you want to like
he's like like we were talking about
prior um with uh Pierce from the from
the Raiders just a guy that you know
makes inspires people to want to play
for him not just play because he's
coaching you know he's he's leading
Charles Bay like he'll lead you into the
fight like there's a fire in the court
you you may might end up joining you
that's something that you're like all
right like I want to play for this guy
and that's the best one I've played for
I I like that and it's like that is a
distinction like playing for a coach but
playing for a coach and eay was more of
the ladder for you so that's beautiful
okay last Celtics question when you went
on Duncan show D riton show you were
talking about the finals against the
Warriors and you very confidently said
that you don't feel like they were the
better team they were just the more
disciplined team first what do you think
is the balance between talent and
discipline and how do you bridge that
Gap yeah I think that you know Talent
can carry you you know it can get you
there but when you are there like
there's going to be things that you
don't expect to happen and like even
with the most talented teams at times
you look at them they're there's no way
they lose that game and then you look up
and you're like oh this team's beating
them by 15 or 10 all because whether
it's they're more physical or whether
they're playing the right way all the
entire way time because
sometimes with Talent you realize like
oh we are this talented so we've been we
can get away with playing in isolation
because you know that's who we are and
then you look up and you're like dang
isolation is not really working for us
anymore now we have to play together and
when we play that way we're hard to
guard but it's something that you have
to be mindful of and consistent and I
thought that's Warriors do like the
Warriors back then especially they were
a team that even if they shot a bad shot
that air balled hit the backboard they
weren't changing how they played they
still were cutting they still were
moving they still were disciplined on
every single thing that they did and I
thought that you know that series we
went away from it we there was times and
games where we like there's no way they
can beat us because you would look up
you be like oh yeah that we got this and
there was other games where it's like
this is not the team that I know and I
think that's where I said a discipline
piece came in and you can give them
credit for that as well because you know
guys played out of their minds that that
series too you know the Wiggins the
pools you know guys like that who really
impacted the series and then you know
Steph was Steph and um
you look at back at that series and
you're like okay they had what they
needed but I still think that we were we
were that team you still think you all
were the better team okay so as we talk
about talent and discipline and that
balance what's the Mavericks balance
right now of talent and discipline yeah
I think that like you said we're very
talented our discipline comes more on a
defensive end that's our discipline
that'll be the true test for us is
that's a test on you that's a test on me
and my my leadership capabilities and if
I'm even you know that guy to be able to
lead in a way because I look back and
with this team like we play the right
way of basketball we play a fun way of
basketball you know we kick the ball
ahead guys are able to play we play in
transition we play fast I think we were
originally we were top three in the pace
I don't know what we are statistically
right now but we play as a game on the
offensive end that's really flow for we
know what it's like to play with one guy
on the court versus another like ky's on
the court by himself versus Lucas on the
court by himself or if they're sharing
the court together we know how to play
so really for us it's going to be
maintaining a discipline and a sense of
what our defensive principles are and
also belief you know belief in this fact
that our staff does is one of the best
staffs in the league in my opinion
because they put hours into the plans
they prepare for us and they watch so
much film and they're very detailed and
and when we make mistakes it's not
because they didn't tell us about the
mistakes is because we chose to do our
own thing and that belief is going to be
huge for us throughout this year because
you know the they do a great job of
preparing us and I got to give them
credit is that you know def defensively
we weren't to a standard that we were
supposed to be especially to start the
season we've gotten there a little bit
more recently but there's still room to
improve and we still can really be not
only just a top five offense but I think
we have potential to be there
defensively as well even if we're we got
to get to middle of the pack first work
our way there but but I think that we're
really there yeah well I will say that
should be encouraging to you because
sometimes when I hear players talk about
some of the problems their teams are
facing is they're not really fixable
problems but what you were saying is
something that is is fixable because it
feels like a lot of it is just buying in
completely and then everything will kind
of go as that goes um okay so I'm gonna
make them both every interview that I
watched of you people asked you about
I'mma make them both and as I heard you
talking about it I realized we
completely understand how you feel about
that moment but a vantage point that we
were missing was Donovan's Vantage Point
yes so I asked Donovan to send me a
video of his vantage point of I'mma make
it both and I'm going to play that for
you okay all right I saw we saw them
last week actually and we played them
before we get to the video Yeah and
George Nang had a chance to ice the game
and he missed both free throws and I
walked up to him after the game I said
listen that was almost I'm make them
both moment and we we all started dying
afterwards they ended up winning because
D even play that game but we all started
laughing but I do want to hear what
Donovan said because you know I can tell
you if it's true or it's not no it's
true and it's it's funny I'm excited to
see
[Music]
okay when Grant was like I'mma make them
both I think one of the funniest things
was after he missed the first one he
grabbed the net or he grabbed it after
the second one sorry he grabed a second
one as if like the rim had moved like it
wasn't his fault he missed both um that
was probably the funniest part to me
just because it was like bro like you
done it up
all head back to the Ben but he was mad
confident and we took like 3 minutes in
between the free throw um just to be
like just to stall him out so I think
that was probably the funniest part but
the funniest part to me I think was when
he went up to the net as if like nah it
wasn't my
fault sh had moved left or right for
sure sorry it's all good I actually will
say he's not the first person to say
that because smart was the one who said
that first smart said you walked up to
the rim like it moved and I said in all
honesty bro it went in like the second
free throw with In-N-Out and I was just
mad at the fact that it just wouldn't
fall I was so cuz the first one I was
like I missed completely that was short
the second one with Inn out I was like
wow I've been shooting 90% on the season
till then and I missed two in a row I
hadn't done that yeah and then from then
on I think I'm shooting like 70% from
the free throw non sense but you know it
was fun where I like look at look back
at that I'm like yeah I definitely
pulled the net and and then later on I
actually yelled at Tony Brothers uh and
he was like oh it's not my fault you
miss free thr so like that's another
added that no one
knows but that's why I say like my
relationship with Tony is great because
like we can talk however we want to one
another but I remember he said that to
me and afterwards I didn't say a word I
just walked to the bench but it's like
Al make a both is so iconic because I
mean people Miss to freeos a lot but
they don't declare that they will not do
miss full confidence that I was making
those too like I didn't even think like
otherwise like cuz I was like I shoot
free throws I've done this many times
where shot him at the end of the games
and made them so I was like yeah I'm
going make them both like I was
confident going into it so I miss the
first one I'm still confident shooting
the second one I was like to the point
where like I feel like my biggest thing
always over confidence is like when you
fall on a sword for me so like I'm the
guy like I'm I can talk trash and stuff
like that but when I'm like boastful
about away that's when I when I bite the
bullet sometimes so I'm learning that
little balance yeah about buying the
bullet you know yeah well listen it's
one of my favorite moments it's my it's
my Agent Zero moment it's something I
always remember no totally something
else that people will always remember of
course is your moments with Jimmy Butler
I'm curious when you think about that
moment now that you're so far remov from
it how do you view it now as opposed to
the decision you made when you were in
it I do it again like I look back at
that moment and I always say like if you
ask Jimmy he definitely like when he F
when I made shot the three he said hell
no you're not here and of course after I
was like no I'm here and that's why we
did the I'm here too f is what Jimmy
said and we went head to-head and I
don't remember what we said when we head
to head we were just I think we were
just yelling at one point yeah and I
still like think that's like a part of
you know basketball it's a part of the
game and that Competitive Edge is like
it inspires you to play harder and play
play more and yeah it might boost might
to be the best they could Poss I'd
rather play you at your best or at your
worst I'd rather see that at a Jimmy I'd
rather you know you know he beat me that
night and I said that's remember at the
interview after the game I said yeah he
got the best of me the night and he has
to do it again and the next game I think
I perform better and game after that and
then game seven they ended up winning
but I felt like throughout the series I
think Jimmy had a I know Jimmy had two
crucial games for them that made them
win and then the other five we had other
guys like Caleb Martin and guys like
that who stepped up but I look back to
that moment and say like I do it again
because if one of those shots don't fall
on their end whether it's struer is or
somebody else then no one talks about it
so I'm still that guy that's going to
say like I'm going to challenge and
compete to the end and not look think
otherwise yeah so it's bit of just a
curious question but do you think that
that moment and how big that moment got
do you think that that was more about
Jimmy or more about
you I think it was more about Jimmy just
because you know it stays with his
storyline of being a guy that steps up
in those moments and me like yeah I
don't give myself that much credit like
I'm I'm definitely considered a good
Defender and stuff like that and I I
definitely believe that like it was a he
moment because you know people always
see me as a guy that either is the VP
and vice first vice president nice guy
and something like that and they've also
seen me where I've been the competitive
like on the court like who is that guy I
don't even know who like like on
Christmas day me and book get into it
I'm just like often times I'm not how
often does that happen so like it's just
a matter of the moments and I have that
spark plug kind of in myself so I think
it was made up before for Jimmy to give
him the step over in a way of saying
like he's built for this rather than me
where it's like he made a mistake or
poked a bear which I don't think was a
real thing yeah okay so you you don't
necessarily adhere to the okay poke the
bear Narrative of it all I don't so if
you some people call it poking the bear
you call it I just say like he he did he
perform like he did his performance like
he was he was as engaged and made him
make him like he said make him lock him
more but when you look at I always say
just go back and look at who scored
scored those basses at the end like we
didn't score for the last I think seven
minutes of the game and I think I like I
don't know I'm still not fully factual
on it so if you can research it online
you know do it better but like if one of
our guys or we make one more shot I
think it changes the entire game yeah
like it's truly just it's a game of of
moments it's a game of runs it's a game
of moments yeah um okay so I've always
wanted to just talk to you about this 7
seconds into the game you and LeBron
chippy what was going on there uh it's
funny because
that we were in practice and I think I
was challenged in the way of saying like
you you're a physical person but like
like I don't think anybody fears you or
intim is intimidated by you and I was in
a way like in that practice I kind of
like took it out on the guys in practice
and um during that day that next game I
didn't even like that wasn't an
intentional thing like I remember I just
stood in front of him and kind of stood
him up and then he tried to run through
me and so that's when it like kind of I
me I look back to that moment where they
challenged me and I was just like you're
not about to run through me so I threw
my shoulder into him and Braun neither
one of us were like ready to fight or
move on past it but it was like okay
like he was kind of taken back by it
like wait like normally people would
either be intimidated or like be like
move out the way like stuff like that
because he's a big dude like I'm not GNA
say that hit he definitely when he hits
you you feel it so when I did it back
like all the referees were surprised too
and we just kind of like kind of kept
walking as if nothing happened and we
got double text for when I don't think
anything was really going on it's just
the league you know League how it is now
so uh but from there like the rest of
the game it was just a physical bang
bang game and you know if you asked Bron
about the moment I would love to hear
his response on what he thought
initially like after the game like cool
but like initially I would love to hear
those yeah like that initial bump it's
probably like a well this is really
interesting to me because I would love
for you to talk about the importance of
not backing down to LeBron James because
I I think that however you decide to
react or not react in those moments is
obviously judged by fans they are going
to have like a hypothesis on it but
LeBron does too so what is that that you
have to think about in those moments
yeah for me like I've always been big on
never backing down from anyone and
that's how I kind of live my life is
that like like no matter what standing
or person you are like I'm willing to
speak up or like be a guy that's going
to not be pushed over around like and
there's definitely going to be a level
of respect but not going to ever be you
know pushed around and looked at and I
think that comes from a guys of love and
respect back too because like anytime I
I've have jerseys at my house and I tell
whether it's the player I ask or Stars
whoever it is I say until you respect me
as a player like I don't want your like
don't give me your jersey and the day
that you respect me like you give me
your jersey and that's like that's going
to be my signal of saying like Okay I
earned this guy's respect and like I'll
have to continue like proving and
showing why I earned it later as the
career goes on and I think I I ended up
getting bronze Jersey that following
like week or like when we played them
next because I asked Marie and I was
like listen this is what I tell people
all the time I think during that game we
didn't have the conversation of course
because he was probably pissed but I
text ke said look just tell him this
blah blah blah and then that's when I
got it so I was like that's felt cool to
me because for a guy of his standing and
stature and the career he's had like to
earn a person's respect is is going to
be huge for me wow so he related to
LeBron that he wants the Jersey but he
only wants that Jersey if you respect
him and soon enough you got the Jersey
yeah what did that mean to you it meant
a lot because you know it's Bron like
I'm not I'm not going to be like this
humble or like this not like I grew up
watching this dude you know like he's U
one of the best players ever if not the
you know can arguably one the so um I
look at it and I'm like pretty it's
pretty cool to be able to have a a
written like not just a signature but a
note on the jersey in my house like
that's something out my my friend back
home I FaceTime that night I was like
bro you're not GNA believe this yeah I
know that's a wild what did he write uh
honestly I have to read it because like
I don't remember off the top of my head
because you know like there's a bunch of
guys like when I got KDs last year
during or was it two years two years ago
during when we played them when one eay
that year went to the finals like it's
just like things like that matter you
know and I think that for players
especially that aren't you know the JT
Luca people like that like especially in
the league some guys would be afraid to
even ask and I like I encourage guys
like don't be afraid to ask but also
like truly like work to get to that
point where now they look at you and
don't just think of you another player
like someone they can look in their
career be like oh yeah he was a decent
Defender he he was a tough guy like he
did this or he knew how to do this and
that's all I've ever wanted like I could
care less about admiration from the like
the world or like the recognitions and
this like I've always just said if my
peers admire me that's all that matters
to me and if I can earn that that's
that's what really really shows my true
verification you know yeah that's really
great and you deserve that that's that's
a really good story um just because I
love this so much I'm curious is there
just any other Jersey that it like
really means a lot to you that this
player said I respect you and you can
have the Jersey you mentioned you have
LeBron you mentioned you have KD those
were two of the two of the highest for
sure um like when I got Lucas last year
was kind of cool before I even played
with him because like Luca is tough and
like I I don't have JT's jersey yet like
people like that like and that would be
a truce cuz I don't want you to give to
me your your friend like it keep it
straight basketball it's purely like
viewership of basketball and um I'm
trying to think of who else I have on
the wall like there's a bunch of guys I
think I have a like 15 jerseys so far
and I'm hoping to collect more as time
goes on but um not just it's not just
star players too sometimes and sometimes
it's the guys that even like you believe
like they're going to be something good
too so I want to make sure that like I
told I think I told giannisis I don't
have giannis's yet and I don't know if
that's because he doesn't respect me or
if it's because of uh like the fact that
he's a guy that like to his career like
I don't think I'll get it the entire
career career until the last game like I
really think that's how he is mentally
like he's like I might respect you but
like from my viewpoint like at the end
of my career that's when I'll show you
the respect back because like right now
we're now on the same team we're not
friends we're not buddy buddy like let's
move on and I'm I respect that too so
like for me it's like every game we you
see us try and battle I love that and
you know what you're gonna get that
you're GNA face JT you're gonna get that
J because obviously you know he affects
you but I feel what you're saying you're
like I was your teammate I was your
friend I need you to see me as an
opponent this is for you absolutely
that's that's really great so as we kind
of talked about these moments that you
had some that are Infamous some that are
just funny etc
etc you do not strike me as a person who
likes confrontation or conflict or like
I would say seeks it out yet you do sort
of end up in these moments and I'm
curious how you feel like both of those
things are true so I would say this like
I've always been a person that like I
don't shy away from any conversation
like I'd rather have conversation and
stuff like that and sort it out even in
life like I'd rather be very vocal
honest and direct and like if you don't
like something say it like I'd rather
deal with it in the moment than like you
boil up and then it everything comes all
at once and we could have handled this
weeks ago yeah so like that's kind of
how I approach it and on the floor like
very I'm like probably the most one of
the most competitive people you'll meet
and so like that tracks in any type of
life whether it's card games as you
remember in space Oh yes uh car you can
tell get tell that story listen you can
tell that story I'm G let you do it I
won't tell the story I just want to say
one thing for the audience I was not who
messed us up do you agree with that when
it mattered okay I'll take that but go
ahead okay yes then who messed us up
when it matter I did I tried to I tried
to throw in the moment I should have yes
I know goad Okay so
um in that regard like I always get in
these moments because like it's not like
I initiate things I'm never a person if
you watch me on the court I'm never the
one that's like talking trash with
somebody across the way but like if
someone talks to me that's why I'm not
gonna let you just talk and not move on
you know I'm a guy that's always going
to go kind of fight back and I think
that's why you know that that edge comes
out too at times where it's like you see
where like oh Grant's locked in today
you know like kind of that same same
reaction where it's like sometimes I
need that where it's like there may be a
game where you feel like you're just
kind of floating out there and then that
that initial thing happens you're like
oh yeah now I'm really really determined
to be there yeah but then there's other
guys like the Pat bevs and those guys in
the league who talk more who like that's
how they get themselves motivated I'm
not a talker like my talking is nerdy so
I try my best just to be quiet till I
need
to amazing okay just so you know we just
hit four do you have 15 more minutes I
got time okay perfect um I've heard you
say that KD is the hardest player in the
league to guard but that Steph is the
most impactful player in the league I
think that's a really important
distinction even though it's likely a
thin line in the distinction can you
tell me your top five most impactful
players in the league they don't have to
be an order but just
five that's actually the most difficult
questions I've been asked um Steph is
definitely on there just because of his
like Steph and Kay are both on there
just because you know K I remember when
he saw that I said he said I come off
pin Downs too I said yeah I know it's
like come off pin down like I get it but
like I'm saying those two for sure just
because their shot making ability and
the the way they kind of impact the team
um I feel like Luca's on that list jic
is on that list um because you know
goodness they control the game and
that's something that's special to watch
when you either play against them or
play with them yeah Luca's Pace that
yeah yeah it's funny because this guy
looks like he just sits around smokes
cigarettes and you know all this stuff
even I don't think he smokes but like in
just in that sense he was saying God
just is on the on the side of the road
hanging out he comes out and get drops
40 um but so those four for sure and
then that last spot's probably the
hardest spot to to decide right now
because you could give it to the MBS you
give it to maybe JT you could give it to
like Hal Burton right now how he's
hooping like Pacers aren't that good
without how he's playing right now you
know and they w't wouldn't be able to
play that way and so that last spot's
probably the most difficult to say um um
trying to think of teams I'm missing
even Giannis like this how he is so
imposing downhill um Victor could be
there one day Shay gilgas you know like
there's a bunch of guys in that list but
I'll give it to um trying to think of
who who moves without the ball as well
not the sac I'm trying to go let's go
each roster Sacramento no even know
dearen those guys no golden state no la
la kawhai maybe man know um I mean I
will say this I mean it feels like the
very obvious answer it is likely why you
didn't Sam him I don't know if you put
LeBron on your list I hadn't yet yeah
because oh is that the reason the only
reason I didn't put LeBron on the list
is because this LeBron is a little more
jump shot moded and he definitely
impacts the game in terms of like how he
he he probably sees the game better than
any player in the league yeah but um in
terms of like the constant motion and
stuff like that it's not the same
because you know he has other like ad is
going to get the ball in the post at
times like it's be a little he's a
little B more passive toward the end the
game when it needs to be so that's what
I'll say ja I haven't played against him
this season yet but he has a potential
to get there one day a shot it's relying
on his shot yeah for sure um so I'll
give it
to she who's made it to the finals every
year so JT or I was it certainly feels
like especially this stretch Jason is on
a different he's on a different so you
got to give it to JT like I feel like
that's the one give it to and then you
can argue and be later on yeah for sure
okay so tell me the one performance that
you have been on the floor for that just
still has you in awe when you think
about it there's either it's got to be
between JT 60o game that I witness and I
was like yo this guy is different and
then honestly I can say that about any
of Lucas's games like watching him play
and you're just like out you're me and
if you just watch reactions on bench
sometimes hopefully if you like second
half when we we're in front of the our
bench where we're playing offense you
can just see me and Dudley beside each
other just look at each other just go
like
bro like this is crazy this is crazy
like this is crazy to witness like and
it seems
effortless and I'm just looking at this
man and I wasn't even on the game where
he scored 60 20 and 20 like I I wanted
to be at that New York New York Knicks
game where he scored 6020 and who knows
I might get it this season but like this
man is just ridiculous and it's there's
no comparison across the league because
yo can make things look easy but he's
look more passive than he is like trying
to be aggressive scoring like he at his
best he's when he's moving getting guys
involved and then he is get his buckets
every now and again trots down the floor
Luca like legit there's not a moment on
the court that you don't have to be
focused because if he has a ball in his
hands there's a either a side that side
step left no matter how many times you
think you can block it people just don't
yeah and then getting downhill one two
slow step either lay up or throwing it
behind his head it's just special
basketball to watch yeah okay so you
have now seen Luca gamewinners up close
and personal oh it happened to me twice
in Boston so I saw it then too you've
seen it on both sides but now that he's
your teammate like what does he tap into
mentally to be able to perform in those
clutch moments and the ways that he does
I think just his work that he puts in
every single day like he just knows the
and he sees the game well like and
I think the best thing about Luca is
when he's challenged he steps up like I
didn't know that about him I didn't know
how he took when someone yelled at him
to do this or do that maybe you might
get a backlash in a moment like oh shut
up or like this like he might be pissed
but when it like it hits him immediately
so if I'm like are you GNA guard
somebody probably I don't say that to
him I say that I say that to JT cuz JT
and I that's how we talk but like for
him it's like if you said that he made
he then locked in from then on like that
dude's not scoring and like even just
watching last night when we guarded
Minnesota and cat like I think we were
double teaming cat I think a lot of the
game and there was times we just let let
luuka go in isolation and I don't think
I don't know if cat scored once once in
that in that situation so it's like
people always talk about Luca not being
cold a Defender it's like when you watch
him play like he's pretty good isolation
Defender when you watch him yeah well I
think again I think so many things about
Luca go back to Pace because when you're
seeing him move you're almost deceived
into thinking like he is slow but it's
actually that he's choosing to be slow
in that moment then he switches here
yeah and you're like whoa and the best
thing that he does is stop like yeah
that's probably the hardest thing for an
athlete because you know there's a bunch
of guys who can really vertically or
really linearly go run and go right but
the ones who were able to stop and
change direction at like James hard and
similar like James is a guy like you
would never think James is lining up for
a 40- yard dash and be like oh that
dude's gonna win right but when you see
him on the court like this man's burst
and then go from going downhill to then
just stopping to shoot a step back it's
crazy his balance is crazy so luuka has
that too for sure um so I wanted to talk
to you a little bit about this because
one thing I was unaware of is how tapped
in you are to your feelings you're very
tapped into mental health um you have
done a lot of interviews based on it and
I know that it is a mission that you
have you know kind of Taken on as just
VP of the PA you talk a lot about it to
the rookies and I know a few drafts back
you and Tyrese halber and actually went
and spoke to the green room and vites
about the league and you were talking to
them about the importance of being able
to stay level headed in this league and
you said that there will be so many
times in the league where you feel like
it is you against the world what moment
in your NBA career did you most feel
like it was you against the
world I think where I felt like it was
me against the world was a bunch of
times like the even just the little
moments that you said the make them B
for the uh Jimmy Butler moment or the
things I've had in the past where they
haven't gone well like you feel like no
one's on your side and then you have to
re understand that like one you have
teammates that may support you but even
if they may be frustrated in the moment
like I know they weren't happy that I
got into it with Jimmy that night so
like um like understanding that like
yeah like it's bound to happen so being
prepared enough to understand that yes
it may happen but how do you respond to
it it's always about the response it's
never about the the mistake that was
made or or the in the m in the moment he
of the moment it's all about how you
look back on it and say either I'm going
to take this and shy away from it and
kind of come out of this with no you
know confidence or belief in myself or
I'm going to come out and say listen it
happened but I'm not going to let it
happen again and that's something I
always preach to the rookies is that you
know there's going to be times it may
not even be basketball it may just be in
life that you feel like you're helpless
and yes you have people here that can
help you and I want you to always know
that but in the event that you feel like
you there's no one you can talk to and
everything else like understanding that
you persevering through that moment
rather than letting it drain you and
take you out of whatever you're doing
you'll realize after the fact that it
was the most important special thing
you've done in your life and no matter
how small or big that is you know and I
feel like mental health is as K Love and
Demar and guys who come out and Rubio
store most recently the players Tribune
I always look at guys like that and see
how you
know how how it how really impactful it
is for guys are in a similar Market that
they may not be able to have the same
voice and it's so important in life not
just from athletes not just from you
know entertainers um down to your your
mom and dad even your grandparents and
understanding how you feel in every
single day and how to respond from the
obstacles that are put in front of you
like I always say God puts those
obstacles in front of you for a reason
and he knows you can persevere he's your
strong you're you're his strongest
Warrior so you have to fight and
continue to fight because if you don't
then giving up does nothing for either
one of us so what are what were your
tools in those moments whether it was
the Jimmy or I'mma make them both how
did you use selft talk or what were you
kind of saying to yourself so that you
didn't get consumed by okay the world's
against me right now I'm a so I'm a
person that either like sometimes I can
kind of put things away like I don't try
not to look at and then try and focus on
things outside of basketball and
positive and then or then come back and
reflect on okay what actually happen
that because in the moment you're so
focused on like oh I should have done
this or should have done that like if
you give yourself time to step away to
come back to approach a problem a lot of
times you have success and and answering
it but also um like you said selft talk
or trying to um do things that make you
feel kind of happy you know like for me
it can be G it could be video games it
could be spending time with family and
friends whether it's cards or dominoes
or bowling and things of that nature and
um finding something that makes you
happy is huge because um the world can
be dark so finding a little light every
now and again can really really help you
for sure yeah I I also read that you
said you know getting a mental health
professional was like the number one
factor that led to your improvements yes
how so and what did that mental health
struggle look like for you absolutely so
um whether it's therapy whether it's
like a mental health coach um even just
a partner you know having someone to
communicate with in not only your times
of need but also in times where you
don't need anything um I think is really
huge and critical because mental health
coach that I had Russ he was um a person
that was able to give me tools to
evaluate moments we had a a principle C
separate Embrace evaluate so you
separate from the emotion whether it is
whether it's anger whether it's sadness
um you have embrace it acknowledge it
saying that yes I may be mad right now
and like being mad is temporary you know
understanding that this is not something
you live with like it's not like you're
mad 247 when you wake up in the morning
just mad for waking up and then
evaluating on why you're mad so now I
know I'm mad so what's the reason like
am I just mad because you know my hand
look weird and for some reason I was
concerned with why my hand looks weird
what kind of senses that make yeah like
it's so those principles is kind of how
I live my life in a way now and
understanding trying understand the
emotions that I'm dealing with every
single day and whether that's sadness
happiness even in times where I'm happy
why am I happy am I just happy to wake
up like that's a good thing am I happy
because I got a sentimental gift from my
mom that was like something that I
hadn't had since childhood and that's
the reason why I'm happy is just happy
just from seeing your face and being
like hey Tay it's been a while since
I've seen you being happy to be able to
hang out like stuff like that like just
being understanding of why I'm happier
in a moment or why I'm sad or mad yeah
so what am I to say I mean as like an
enormous compliment um as somebody who I
consider you a good friend and we have a
great professional relationship
too you are yourself like all of the
time and I think that it's very
refreshing in a league where it feels
like everybody just kind of wants to be
cool and their cool is determined by
what everyone else thinks is cool but
you you call yourself a nerd and a geek
and you're very comfortable in a way
that's very admirable to be vulnerable
and talk about yourself what power have
you found in that because I would assume
there have been times in your life where
somebody maybe wanted you to shy away
from that oh yeah all the time you know
it's something that I always say if you
can stay true to yourself and understand
your value and not let others control or
dictate that like you live a life that
you want to live and a happy living and
it's not saying you have to be
comfortable or content with what you are
and you're not like you don't have to
change there's may be little things you
may need to change to improve your life
but um I never try my best to look to
other others for validation I try my
best to give myself confidence in my
Approach and understand that yeah it's
okay to like these things it's okay to
like car games or Pokemon or stuff like
that and like their interests their
Hobbies or things everyone has them so
whether it's the trendy one that's
happening right now or something that
could be trendy 20 years from now who
who's to tell so I try my best never be
to be judgmental on opinions I try my
best to look at everything as kind of
like not how I say there's gray area and
everything you look at so um
understanding and being confident on the
things that I enjoy and being willing to
be able to listen to something new and
and maybe add things to things that
maybe I didn't have familiarity or
interest in before now I love country
music I used to hate it and now it's
like I listen to it now not just because
I moved to Texas I started listening in
Boston
and even just house or like different
styles of music regon like jazz like
Blues like I try my best to take bits
and pieces of everybody and certain
artist I might be like yeah I'm not a
fan of his work but I like this you know
like so just being able to you know
challenge yourself to expand and enjoy
more yeah and that is truly cooler than
the ladder I mean what you were saying
is cooler than any other way uh two more
questions for you one of the big things
that we are doing this season is shining
a light on other the people who helped
us get where we are so who has given you
your biggest assist off the court I feel
like my grandfather um gave me my
biggest assist because
his honestly his perseverance growing up
like being able to hear his stories even
though I didn't witness them like gave
me a perspective of life like getting
the job done is what he always just to
say get the job done and whatever that
job may be like he said like if you were
to contractor roof or stuff like that
rather than procrastinating and looking
around like ah you know I'll get it done
eventually like get it done in a moment
then afterwards you look at yourself
like I have all this free time this is
where I could do the stuff I wanted to
do yeah like same way like I I try my
best to when I look at my house right
now like okay what needs to get done
let's get it done and that way
afterwards we can all be happy that we
got it in after my like the stereo
system was one of the biggest things
that I wanted to get done now living in
a home where I can watch movies and I'm
happy that I'm watching them rather than
trying to like turn the volume of all to
the max because I couldn't hear anything
yeah and so just little things like that
and understand that issues are going to
stay issues till they're solved so being
mindful of what they are and being able
to attack those from the start and not
have to overthink on what I should do or
what should I what I shouldn't do and
that was also a really cool and kind of
subconscious way with to get the job
done to really teach you about
discipline like he instilled that in you
probably without you even realizing it
just by making it as simple as get the
job done when it calls for it so that's
great um okay lastly I want to give you
a chance to talk about buay for a second
I because I personally have seen Grant
take Jason T's money
so you said that and watch this you're G
to start something now because he's
going to come on this and tell about the
money that I owed him originally from
the space tournament my first year and
I'm listen I kind of gained it back but
at the same time like he's going to
bring it up so but vay is a dangerous
game yes and you love it who have you
like bested like they're still thing
about that another thing that's gonna
start something you try to start
something right now um oh I'm just gonna
keep it friendly we have a friendly game
going on right now uh in the Dallas
Mavericks uh I was up on Luca let's just
say Luca did a a good job of fighting
back but um but prior to that you know
we'll just we'll just uh I'm not even
going to say a name from so y'all taught
Luca Bay Noca knows Luka knew but I mean
he knew once he entered the league like
he didn't know when he came over but you
don't know like who tght I I think he
start he originally said he played with
uh Wesley
Matthews uh who else was on that team he
had he had a group that he played but
it's the first year he's played since so
like this group like we bringing it back
together like the playing cars on the
plane even if it's not for huge amounts
of cash yeah it could be although it
normally is yeah trust me nine times out
of 10 it is I've seen aggressive losses
I've seen people lose Millions which is
truly wow there were a lot of people
that walked out of that bubble oh that
Bub we can get that's a whole another
podcast episode bubble blay is like a
different kind of episode bub that
should be his own show Bubble Boo 100%
oh there's some stories that Toronto
Raptor series had some some interesting
times from that one let's just say that
okay this is the last thing I'm ask tell
me your favorite bubble Bay story that
you can tell like CU because I agree
that was those those are the best
stories that's the only reason I learned
how to play buay I played buay with Kima
javante green and uh danan Hernandez and
one other person I forget who the other
one was there but that's the reason why
I learned let's just say our pots were
definitely like way smaller than the
pots that were playing behind us I've
never seen so much cash on the table in
my life yeah on the pots that I was
playing playing behind us so those
stories uh let's just say there were a
bunch of friendly you know uh
discussions
um that took place and a lot of uh there
was nothing uh I don't believe physical
but who
knows but truly the best times like it's
it's such a fun game and I I think it's
really cool that buay is just sort of
like this thing everyone does in the NBA
it just makes it even more of a
fraternity I honestly think you should
bring it outside of it because like it's
it's a game that like you don't have to
play for $20 $50 $100 a hand stuff like
that you can play for a dollar a hand
and still have fun playing it and
whether whatever you're making and it's
something that not only can be very fun
but also something that you talk trash
with and goof off with like I play with
my friends from home where we were
playing like I think $5 hands and they
were like I'm never playing this game
again I was like listen that's what it
does to you that's what it does to you
you say that and the next you know next
week they were playing by themselves I
promise you it's addictive it's
addictive Grant you are truly a pleasure
thank you so much for doing the show I
feel like I walked away with like so
many different Little Gems and I'm
really happy to see how you have settled
into Dallas how much you love it and I
mean I always see you annually what at
Jason's golf tournament why party I'll
be seeing you but always a pleasure and
thank you so much thanks for having me
on of course of
[Music]
course